[Applause]
[Music]
this is how the prices right is made The
Price is Right premiered on CBS on
September 4th 1972 back then the wheel
didn't exist only three contestants
played and each episode was only 30
minutes in 1975 the wheel was introduced
and episodes were twice as long the 1975
version is still used today
drew Carey took over for Bob Barker as
the show's host in 2007 I realized what
an institution the show is and how long
it's been on the air and Bob Barker
himself gave me the best advice
Bob said the best advice is to try not
to copy him and I couldn't come out
trying to be like Bob Bart I had to be
me so I did I came out and I tried to be
me so I wasn't trying to mimic Bob
Barker or a Bob Barker I was just trying
to be myself and not screw it up it took
me a couple years to think of it as my
show instead of a show that somebody
else had that I was kind of like
caretaking or something now I feel like
it's my show totally I always know it's
gonna be a roomful of excited people
jumping around and it's exciting for me
I come in about you know between 11:15
11:30 and opponents of music in my
dressing room sometimes not man I put on
a TV or whatever and sometimes are just
quiet and I get dressed and they want me
in the makeup chair at 11:45 sometimes
in there at 11:50 makeups really quick
as you saw it takes like three minutes
and I'm then I just sit there and they
start to show and I walk kind of stage
and then I I have my lunch and then I do
the same thing when I go home it's great
I work about 20 hours a week
Drew's right-hand man George Gray
started as the show's announcer in 2011
it's gonna be manna it's such a family
it's it's amazing to be here every day
is great people say are you having fun
it's you know I mean you make it people
Street comes from self course three
other guys in history have had the job
permanently besides me and two of them
passed away with the job I mean that's
nobody wants to leave I'm so lucky to
have this iconic gig to appear on the
show all audience members have to do is
show up and wait in line their producer
Stan interviews around 300 candidates to
choose who gets to come on down for
season I interview about 53,000 people
which is horse big what do you think
about it's a lot of people I know
essentially what I'm looking for is
somebody who anybody who has the energy
and
their energy a lot of people start off
early brain but if you can't maintain it
you'll get the people a book yeah I'm
really excited to be here I'm from Iowa
and it's like you just see the black
plummeting because everybody starts off
break as they love the show and they're
excited initially but if you can match
my energy and exceed it and maintain it
you have a really good chance of being
on the show but being chosen by Stan is
only half the battle
you have to make it past contestants row
to play a game on stage with drew them
when we're taping the show I mean this
goes for drew George and the models
they're not allowed to help contestants
or tip any them in any way because a lot
of times the contestants will say like
Oh tell me what do you think drew what
do you think to the models and they
can't give anything away because they do
that the models because they're in
rehearsal they do know a lot of stuff
for one thing I grew up without any
money so I really empathize with people
when they win and I'm happy that our to
win anything and just to be on the show
I'm like yeah I get it you know five
hundred bucks isn't a lot of money for a
game show it's a lot of money for people
you know it's a that could make your
week you know it's not like a
life-changing amount but that's like
extra money maybe get to pay a bill
there's a couple games where I'm like
this is a tough game to win and I worry
about people playing it as I don't I
know how hard it is and how but that the
odds are kind of against them because we
have some high percentage win games and
some low percentage win games like
that's too much that we've played today
that's a low percentage win game that's
a hard game to win we have about 20
people that work in our prize Department
they're constantly researching what the
latest trends are in fashion furniture
travel destinations experiences what
people want what do people want today
where the days of the the grandfather
clocks are gone so we're now looking for
what people want today and what's
exciting and going to really get viewers
at home to what these prizes we have a
huge warehouse where we store items at
work
getting new stuff once a prize is one on
the show the contest has to wait till
the show airs and once the show airs
surprise is delivered within 90 days if
I could change come on down to anything
I want what would I make it don't pee
your pants it's time to come on down
that's cuz that's what happens don't
black it out it's time to come on yeah
okay a little bit of reality be good